اسبوعين كنا قد حضرنا في الساعه ستونه من
ضروره الاستعداد لمرحله ما بعد تويتر
كثيرون سنباوا بسيناريو الانهيار اليوم
ماسك اعترف بالورقه الافلاس هو الليث
مستبعدا وغرد بان السعر الذي دفعه لقاء
عمليه الاستحواذ كان غيره عادل كلام وصفي
يبدو دقيقا للغايه ارادات الشركه اقل
بكثير من مصروفاتها ومنذ اليوم الاول ماسك
حمل ميزانيه الشركه 13 مليار دولار ديونا
اضافيه الى جانبي مديونيه الخمسه مليارات
دولار السابقه لعمليه الاستحباب هناك
كارثه وبالفوائد الشركه مول زمان بدفع
مليار ومئتين مليون دولار كفائده على
خدمته الدين البالغه ثلاثه عشر مليارات
وهذه الفائده متغيره ومرشحه للارتفاع
تماشيا مع سياسه البنك الفيدراليه الحاليه
لمعالجه ازمه التضخم في امريكا للعلم ديون
تويتر قبل الاستحواذ
100 مليون دولار فقط مع هذا عانت الشركه
لتحقيق الارباح والان الوضع بات اسوا
بكثير ويستلزم عمليه عاجله حتى البنوك
التي مالت عمليه الاستحواذ تبحث عن من
يشتري السندات في صناديق التحول وعرضت كل
دولارا مقابل 70 سنه فقط وهي محاوله
للتخلص من اي ارتباط مع الشركه على المدى
البعيد الواقع ان الوسيله الوحيده لتظل
الشركه موجوده على المدى القريب هي ان
يقوم ماسك بحل ما في شعوبته بمعنى ان يبيع
اسومه في تسلا ليحصل على الكاش السيوله
ويسدد الديون الشركه كي لا تعلن افلاسها
ماسكه على ذلك ما قيمته عشرون مليار دولار
من اسومه في تسلا وبشكلنا متفرق خلال
العامين الماضيه لكن الى متى قد يختار
ببال البعض ان الامر لن يكون صعبا على
ماسك لكن الحقيقه ان ماسك قد يضطر الى
تاجيل رحلته الى المريخ قليلا امام هذه
المعضلات